green bean casserole is crunchy creamy  and honestly one of my favorite  Thanksgiving sides so let's do it you're  going to start with bacon saute it up  before adding in some flour onions  garlic and letting that saute then  you're going to toss in some milk and  some broth you're then going to add in  your mushrooms spices and fresh herbs  and let that simmer until you have a  nice thick base pour that over your  blanched green beans and let that cook  in the oven for about 30 minutes before  you fry your own onions honestly guys  this is what takes it to the next level  you're going to put that right over your  casserole and you're going to enjoy the  full recipe is at tonysrecipes.com try  this out this Thanksgiving and let me  know what you think